RAE: The thought that I had, sitting here,
while
Nick made that
was that
I think when you-- this course is
gonna be--
not replicated, but it will go on in many,
many parts of the world in many schools.
I think it would be a great idea if it began
with you-- in person if possible, or otherwise
through the magic of video--
giving this--
the lecture you just gave,
which I think is a
really good way of structuring
and purposing
a seminar like this. Now there may be
other seminars that
don't fit that template,
but I would urge you to do that. I mean,
goodness, I--
the idea that we can say how
we're going to impact you in this course...
It's interesting, in fact-- I've taught, now,
easily a hundred courses at Yale.
And that's a question I've never been asked.
And it's--
maybe--
well it's certainly-- the point certainly
is not
some sort of technical expertise.
It is
some kind of cosmopolitan knowledge of
the role of faith in the very complex
history that you're going to be part of.
And some of you will be,
not just part of it, but influential
parts of it.
And it seems quite likely that the
humanizing spirit-- maybe--
"humanizing," I guess, is tendentious in
this context,
but I'll use it anyway-- the humanizing
spirit that is-- that pervades this seminar,
is a pretty good starting place for dealing
with difference. And--
I forget if it's point three or point four, but-- getting from
grudging tolerance
to mutual respect
is no easy task
in many of the world's
arenas.
And it--I would say if you
carry that ambition and
cultivate the skills--
that by itself would be
a worthwhile purpose for this course.
VOLF: You know, I suppose I want to answer this
in the way that--
so what makes me take this course? If I ask
my question of myself-- why do I think this
is really
important? Why am I so excited about it?
What does it do to me?
And maybe you can
pick up something for this, for yourself, or
maybe not, right? That may be. But that--
that's probably the way in which I want to
answer it, and if you ask me,
why my passion about this course?
I think I would say
because I want to bring the idea
of purpose, of the ends,
of human life,
individual life,
institutional
life, organizational life,
to bear upon the functioning
of our very complex world.
I'm really interested-- what really drives
me is
the concept of human flourishing
in the context of a global common good.
And in the world which is
interconnected, interdependent--
different faiths with different visions
of human flourishing-- different visions of the
global common good--
living together side by side.
And if we can learn how not to give up on asking the notion
of purpose,
asking the question of purpose,
and pursuing human flourishing that's broader
than just my own interest
but at the same time learn how to live together
in the way that is mutually enriching--
what a world we would create!
So if I ask myself why am I engaged with it, that's
why I'm engaged with it. I want to roll up my sleeves,
make a better world,
with people of different faiths living
together while not giving up.
My
notion
of human flourishing derives from the venerable
faith tradition
and respecting others who have other venerable
traditions
as well. So I'm hoping
that you'll go away
with the vision
of human flourishing,
with some kind of instruments to how to work
toward realizing that vision,
and working together alongside others
toward that same goal.
BLAIR: For me, I think it's very
simple. I'd like you to better
take out from this
why this is such an important question. I think
it's as simple as that-- that it is really important.
But secondly, and leading on from
Doug and Miroslav--
I hope-- 'cause this is the very best thing about a university-- you can--
probably when-- maybe Fred knows, because he's been out in the
world and come back and so on, but--
the most important thing,
I think,
is to be able
always to gain fresh insights into the world.
And if what this has done has made you think
about--
maybe your own faith,
and maybe your own faith and its place in the
world--
and how it relates to other people-- then that's,
I think, something that's really worth
while. But I think that
the single most important thing you can
get out of this is
to understand that
without
a knowledge of this issue, and
a belief, then,
that is the result of your knowledge, it's
important to act--
if that's what
what you can get out of it, that's-- this is good.